el pueblo somalí una de las grandes
víctimas del cambio climático en su
visita somalia el secretario general de
Naciones Unidas subrayó la compleja
situación que vive la nación africana
Antonio Gutiérrez pidió a la comunidad
internacional un apoyo masivo para
somalia un país que enfrenta una de las
peores sequías en la historia del
continente Naciones Unidas ha creado un
fondo para ayuda humanitaria de 2.6 mil
millones de dólares aunque solamente el
15% del total ha sido cubierto
somalia contribuye con el
0.003% de las emisiones que provocan el
cambio climático Aunque somalia
prácticamente no contribuye al cambio
climático los somalíes están entre las
mayores víctimas Casi cinco millones de
personas sufren altos niveles de
inseguridad alimentaria aguda Y por
supuesto el aumento de los precios
agrava la situación
[Música]
al menos 43.000 personas fallecieron en
2022 en somalia Víctimas de la sequía
que enfrenta el país miles de personas
han buscado mejor suerte migrando a
países vecinos sin embargo su situación
no mejora
nadie nos ayuda No tenemos comida ni
agua ni siquiera ropa ni láminas de
plástico para cobijarnos huimos de la
sequía y llevo 158 días sin comida ni
cobijo para los niños todos los días
salgo a llamar a casas de la ciudad para
pedir limosna para que mis hijos puedan
comer
somalia también experimentan los
horrores de la inseguridad alimentaria
la crisis alimenticia se suma las
consecuencias de conflictos armados el
covid 19 y la crisis climática lo que ha
provocado un nexo de cientos de miles